but then
then there are the people like nicole
hannah jones the elitists within the
democratic party and she is taking aim
michael at the media's coverage of
ukraine
as racist she says if you basically
she's saying if you care you're if
you're particularly upset about what's
happening in ukraine that's because of
your racism
um she is explaining that uh
basically it's well i'm trying to find
the exact real the exact uh tweet that
uh
okay
these admissions of shock that this is
happening in a european country are
ahistorical and also serve to justify
the lack of sympathy for other invasions
other occupations and other refugee
crises involving people's not considered
white
uh and goes on goes on to talk about the
racialized analysis and language that
the reporters need to look internally
because racialized analysts and analysis
and language uncovering ukraine is
obvious she doesn't like people
referring to ukraine as a civilized
country you did that in a tweet she's
probably gonna say you're racist
um because that shows you only care
about the ukrainians because they're
white
because they're white and and nicole
hannah jones insists that we need to
only focus on people with a history of
slavery which is ironic when we're
talking about slavic regions of the
world because last i checked
slavic is where we get the very word
slavery but but to take her point on its
face as you mentioned megan i got in
trouble for a shocking controversial
amazing tweet that i made that i i did
not think was controversial at all
namely this war between russia and
ukraine is the first major war of my
lifetime between civilized nations there
have been other minor wars i think of
the i don't know nagorno-karabakh
conflict not a major war even kosovo i
remember kosovo uh quite well but not a
major war
when you look at the civilized part of
things
left-wing flattery aside i don't think
anyone believes that gaddafi's libya was
the most civilized place or or assad
syria i don't think anyone is going to
go honeymoon in aleppo over paris the
reason this matters
i'm not making any sort of value claim
about uh the relative worth of libyans
versus ukrainians the reason it matters
is because you're talking about a
nuclear former superpower now conquering
what had been a buffer state between
russia and europe world wars have
started for much less than this and
you've got putin who is committing the
invasion is now actually threatening to
use nuclear weapons so the reason i
mention this is because the the global
effects of this war if it continues to
escalate as i think very stupidly the
europeans are and are encouraging it to
right now
the effects could be catastrophic at a
far greater scale than the relatively
minor wars that we have seen for the
past several decades moreover it's just
not true to suggest that there is
there's been no caring by the american
people when war breaks out in countries
where people aren't all white um i mean
you could go down the list i i was at
fox news covering most of them while
they were happening
and so this is another tweet that she
sends out what if i told you europe is
not a continent by definition but a
geopolitical fiction to separate it from
asia and so the alarm about a european
or civilized or first world nation being
invaded
is wait for it
a dog whistle
to tell us we should care because they
are like
us
why are we listening to her about
anything how can any self-respecting
american university employ this [ __ ]
well megan you know the the thing about
dog whistles is that uh the creatures
that hear the dog whistles well they
tend to be dogs you notice the
conservatives here
they're never the ones talking about
these dog whistles so you say hold on if
you're hearing that maybe that says more
about you than it does about me the
irony of course with nicole hannah jones
is that
she is not a real historian she is not a
real scholar she is a propagandist and a
political activist actually the the main
thing that she is known for is the 1619
project from the new york times the
central thesis of which was complete
bunk and yes michael speaking of a
historical who is she to be throwing
that term around
right her claim was that the american
revolution began to protect slavery in
the colonies and it's just not true and
even leftist academic historians pointed
out it's not true she's never really
apologized the new york times sort of
kind of tried to kind of retract it some
months later but they still took out
their errands pushing it right yeah
exactly and you're not it's not going to
work and so no one should take her
seriously and the only reason anyone
really should care about what she says
is because she's a very effective
political activist who has transformed
curricula around the country and totally
misrepresented history and geopolitics
and uh unfortunately when people are
ignorant of history and geopolitics you
find yourself in in sad situations
history repeating itself as tragedy and
force